hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of our readers Newton who asks I'm
currently working as an administrative
manager however I've thought of
concentrating my business on the real
estate because I own two houses and have
acquired some land for construction I've
always thought I could earn more in my
own business there Wagner network I
could quit work your advice will always
help Newton so Newton there's nothing
wrong with starting a business part-time
it's a great way to get started a lot of
entrepreneurs jump headfirst into a new
business the runner for three months run
out of momentum run out of energy and
have to close down the business and go
get another job and what you really have
to understand as an entrepreneur is you
need to keep the momentum going and
allow your time to help you build that
up so it's better to start a business
part-time do work every day to move that
business board even if it's just you
know a couple hours a day and over time
that will grow and your chances of being
successful will increase dramatically
it's much better than doing it for a
couple months full time and then not
allowing for your momentum to grow a lot
of entrepreneurs will fail usually
because they may not have that great an
idea but also because they haven't
allowed for the momentum to grow and
they shut their business down to
students because they've run out of
momentum and other money so it's a great
way to start if we can do a part time
you have money committing from your job
and as you get more confident with your
business eventually hopefully you'll be
able to put and do your business
full-time you ask about the real estate
business I will always encourage
entrepreneurs when thinking about what
businesses start the follow something
they're super passionate about really
excited about and can invest tons of
time and energy into it sounds like you
really like real estate if you own two
houses and on a plot of land that you
want to build on so I would just make
sure before you know cleaning too that
you're you're really excited but real
estate you think you can do you know
invest a lot of time and energy into
that and that's following your heart
the last bit of advice is if you're
gonna have a job as for all
entrepreneurs if you're you know
thinking of starting a new business if
you're if you're going to take a job try
to take a job that gives you more than
money try to take a job where you can
learn something from it
so look at the job here and now you know
if you're going to have a job
try to use something from that job that
you can later implement it to put into
your own business so is there something
from the job you're you're in now that
will help you learn for when you run in
your own business maybe there's extra
roles or responsibilities you can take
on to give you that knowledge and to
give you the training without you know
wasting your own money on it that can
then help you later build your business
so a quick example of this I have a
really kind of jobs but when I was in
university I was already running my own
business and I used my courses to help
me build my business so I created my own
course in you know small business and
all my marketing assignments all related
around my business that I was currently
running so I was able to use the
resources of my university to help me
plan and grow my business so it's a
great way to be able to leverage stuff
that you're already doing to help you
you know develop your skills and later
be able to run your business more
effectively so I hope that helps if you
guys liked the video please give it a
thumbs up I'd also love to hear feedback
if you want to leave a comment below the
video and stay tuned for the next
episode
you